مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا قرار الحكومه
الفلسطينيه اقتطاع جزء من رواتب موظفي
قطاع غزه كما يب ليس الا ملمحا جديدا
للخلاف بين حركتي فتح وحماس ولانقصان
الفلسطيني القائم منذ عشر سنوات هناك وفد
من حركه فتح يستعد للتوجه الى قطاع غزه
لبحث سبل انهاء هذا الانقسام بينما اكدت
حماس ان اي لقاء مع وفد حركه فتح يجب ان
يكون في اطار وحضور فصائلي كامل كما طالبت
بالتراجع عن قرار الخصم من وتب الموظفين
وكذلك عن فرض ضرائب على وقود محطه توليد
الكهرباء في غزه كعربون اخلاقي لعقد
اللقاء تقرير فتحي
اسماعيل لا اقوى ربما من هذه الاشتباكات
دلاله على حقيقه الصراع بين الفلسطينين
والاحتلال الاسرائيلي او على الاقل ما
يفترض ان يكون عليه المشهد امام تنكر
اسرائيل لحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني لكن مثل
هذا المشهد بدا يتاكل لا سما مع فقدان
الكفاح الفلسطيني بوصلته بالانقسام بين
الضفه والقطاع والقطيعه بين حركتي فتح
وحماس فرغم ما تمليه المرحله من توحيد
الصفوف ضد الاحتلال خاصه مع اندلاع
انتفاضه الاسرى داخل المعتقلات والسجون
الاسرائيليه ورغم جولات الحوار العديده
بين الفصلين تبدو الخلافات بينهما مرشحه
لتصعيد
جديد اخر تجلياته دعوه السلطه الفلسطينيه
حركه حماس الى الالتزام بخطه الرئيس محمود
عباس لانهاء الانقسام واستعاده الوحده
الوطنيه دون شروط متهمه اياها باعاقه
مساعيها لدعم سكان القطاع وجبا الايرادات
لصالحها خطه سيحملها الى غزه قريبا وفد من
حركه فتح غير ان حماس اكدت انها لا تعتزم
الاستجابه لاي شروط بل اشترطت هي حضور كل
الفصائل للقاء الوفد الزائر كما اشترطت ان
يلغي عباس كل القرارات التي اصدرها بحق
القطاع فقبل ايام قررت السلطه الفلسطينيه
فرض ضرائب على وقود محطه الكهرباء في قطاع
غزه واقتطاع نحو 30% من اجمالي قيمه رواتب
موظفي القطاع عن شهر اذار مارس الما
بررت الحكومه تلك الخطوات بالصعوبات
الماليه لكن الرساله فهمت في غزه على انها
سياسيه وتهدف الى تعميق معاناه سكان
القطاع الذي تديره حركه حماس منذ نحو ع
اعوام سارع قاده كبار في الحركه بينهم
خالد مشعل الى اتهام عباس باستهداف القطاع
وتنفيذ مؤامره وبعيدا عن تبادل الاتهامات
بين الحركتين من يربط تغيير عباس لقواعد
اللعبه مع القطاع بالمساعي الامريكيه
لاحياء المفاوضات الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه
فاللقاء التي عقدها الرئيس ترامب مع قاده
عرب ومع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي انصبت في
مجملها على ما تسميه واشنطن صفقه القرن
وما يمكن ان تحمله من فرض للرؤيه
الاسرائيليه وتفرط بالتالي في الحقوق
الفلسطينيه واذا ما اخذ في الاعتبار ان
الرئيس عباس نفسه سيتوجه قريبا الى واشنطن
للقاء ترامب فان تشددا مع قطاع غزه يكون
ربما مطلوبا اكثر لنجاح الزياره واقناع
الامريكيين ربما بتقديم ما يلزم لاستئناف
محادثات التسويه والاستفاده من الزخم
الرسمي العربي الداعم للسلطه الفلسطينيه
لا سما بعد قمه البحر
الميت ينضم الينا من رام الله الكاتب الصح
محمد هواش ومن غزه الدكتور مصطفى الصواف
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ابدا معك سيد هواش
ما الذي دفع الان الى تحريك هذا الملف ملف
الانقسام ووضع حماس في غزه وتلويح الرئيس
عباس باجراءات حاسمه وغير مسبوقه رغم انه
سبقها باجراءات اقتصاديه كبيره يعاقب فيها
سكان
القطاع
اعتقد ان ما جاء في التقرير سليم من حيث
ربط يعني مبادره الرئيس محمود عباس
بالتحرك الدبلوماسي والتحرك السياسي
وامكان عقد قمه امريكيه فلسطينيه تتناول
موضوع احياء التسويه
السياسيه التسويه التسويه السياسيه متوقفه
عمليا ومتعثر منذ خمس خمسه الى ست سنوات
لا توجد مفاوضات لا توجد حركه سياسيه
حقيقيه كانت محاولات الاداره الامريكيه
محكومه ب يعني الرخاوه
والتراخي والفشل وعدم اظهار حزم حيال
الاطراف الفلسطينيه والاسرائيليه وبالتالي
توقفت المفاوضات الان هناك اداره امريكيه
جديده
لديها اجنده مختلفه ولديها خطاب مختلف
ولديها توقعات ايضا هل اتضح عفوا سي ه
اتضحت هل اتضحت الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
الخطه الامريكيه البنود الامريكيه التي
على
اساسها
[موسيقى]
ستانفورد
نعم هذا هذا سؤال مهم جدا اعتقد بان
الرئيس محمود عباس يستعد لاي موقف امريكي
جديد يستعد يريد ان ان ان تكون هناك وحده
وطنيه فلسطينيه ان ينتهي الانقسام ان تكون
هناك عناوين سياسيه واضحه للشعب الفلسطيني
ان تكون هناك حكومه فلسطينيه واحده ورئيس
فلسطيني واحد يريد ان يعني في في في
المبادره المطروحه انهاء هذا الوضع الشاذ
منذ ع سنوات حتى الان وبالتالي هو يعني
يتخذ خطوات لها طابع جدي ولها طابع ربما
قاسي على الفلسطينيين جميعا ليس فقط على
موظفي ايه قطاع غزه ولكن على كل
الفلسطينيين لذلك هو
يعني يعطي انطباعات جديه بان هذه المره
هناك مبادره سياسيه على الاطراف
الفلسطينيه ان تستجيب لترتيب البيت
الفلسطيني طيب استعدادا لاي مفاجاه
امريكيه استعدادا لاي موقف امريكي جديد
غير متوقع طيب دكتور مصطفى الصواف اين
المشكله اذا كان الهدف هو ترتيب البيت
الفلسطيني انتظارا لاي مبادره دوليه ربما
تاتي في وقت معين او وقت قريب على ضوء
الاداره الامريكيه
الجديده مساء الخير لك ولضيفك ولا اعتقد
ان الاجراءات والخا والق قرارات التي
والتهديد والوعيد الذي يمارسه محمود عباس
ضد جزء اصيل من الشعب الفلسطيني يمكن ان
يؤدي الى ترتيب الاوراق هذا يؤدي الى
لخبطه الاوراق وقلب الطاوله يؤدي الى مزيد
من الانقسام يؤدي الى مزيد من الفرقه من
يريد ان يوحد الشعب الفلسطيني لابد ان
يسمع الى ما يريده الشعب الفلسطيني وليس
كما يقول المثل يعني يكب قربه على هوا
السحاب ربما هذا السحاب لا يسقط على ارض
فلسطين وهذه الاداره الامريكيه الجديده لم
تقدم شيئا حتى نقدم قطاع غزه قربانا لهذا
اللقاء الذي سيجري ما بين محمود عباس
والامريكي ترامب ولذلك لابد من اعاده
القراءه مجددا للواقع السياسي سواء كان
الدولي او الاقليمي وللواقع الداخل
الفلسطيني بما يخدم استراتيجيه فلسطينيه
موحده بما يخدم مصالح الشعب الفلسطيني
دكتور مصطفى ترتيب البيت الفلسطيني في في
المقام الاول يصوب في مصلحه الفلسطينيين
قبل ان نستقبل به اي مبادره دوليه او
خارجيه نعم هذا لو كان هناك ترتيب للبيت
الفلسطيني الذي يجري هو تفسيخ للمفسر
اساسا في البيت الفلسطيني عندما يتم حرمان
اكثر من 40 ال موظف من رواتبهم هل هذا هو
ترتيب للبيت الفلسطيني هل حجه ان هناك خلل
في الميزانيه او هناك يعني ميزانيه غير
مكتمله هل هو فقط على الموظفين في قطاع
غزه ولم يشمل كل الضفه الغربيه هل هذا هذه
الازمه الماليه تعني ان هناك توظيف الان
معلن في في حكومه رام الله انا استغرب
حقيقه من طرح مساله ترتيب البيت الفلسطيني
الذي يجري هو ليس ترتيب هو الذي يجري هو
تقسيم هذا البيت الفلسطيني وزياده الشرخ
الفلسطيني هناك وسائل العده ممكن
استخدامها لترتيب هذا البيت بما يخدم
مصالح الشعب الفلسطيني نعم نحن مع ترتيب
البيت الفلسطيني ولكن على اسس سليمه وليس
على اسس منهاره في الاساس لم تقدم شيء منذ
اكثر من 24 عامس اي سيدي محمد هواش ما هي
الاجراءات الحاسمه وغير المسبوقه التي
يهدد بها الرئيس محمود عباس فيما لو فشل
وفده وفد فتح في التفاوض مع حماس في غزه
على مواضيع لها علاقه بتسليم
السلطه اعتقد بان الموضوع يجب ان ينقسم
الى قسمين او مستويين المستوى السياسي
والمستوى مستوى الاجراءات والخطوات
الاجرائيه بالدرجه الاولى الرئيس يركز على
مفهوم اشراك حركه حماس شريكا وطنيا كاملا
في النظام السياسي الفلسطيني لانهاء
الانقسام
ويقترح الى ذلك انتخابات خلال اشهر معدوده
من ثلاثه الى سته اشهر ان تكون هناك
انتخابات رئاسيه و تشريعيه هذا هو الجوهري
في التوجه الذي يعني قدمه الرئيس محمود
عباس فيما يتعلق بالخطوات الاخرى هي
اشارات اشارات تقول بان حركه حماس اذا لم
تستجب الى هذا التوجه الى هذه الفرضيه
التي تحتاج الى اختبار وتحتاج الى مغامره
بشكل او باخر لان الوحده تستحق المغامره
وتوحيد البيت الفلسطيني وترتيب البيت
الفلسطيني يستحق هذه المغامره اذا رفضت
حركه حماس ترتيب البيت الفلسطيني على هذه
الاسس ورفضت اجراء انتخابات ورفضت انهاء
الانقسام فعلى حركه حماس كما تشير يعني
التوقعات فعلى حركه حماس ان تتحمل مسؤوليه
كامله عن قطاع غزه اذا كانت تريد ان تحتفظ
بقطاع غزه فقط بالسلطه السياسيه والامنيه
وال المقاومه وكل ذلك فعليها ايضا ان
تتحمل مسؤوليه الخدمات الاساسيه التي تقدم
الى قطاع غزه من قبل السلطه المركزيه
الفلسطينيه اكثر وضوح ل تهديد هي هي يعني
لنفهم لنفهم فقط بشكل هذا ليس تهديدا طيب
هذا ليس ته الصر الرسي الم الوحده الاجراء
الاجراء المقابل هو تخلي السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه عن القطاع بما يعنيه من فصل
تام ما بين القطاع والضفه كعقاب لحركه
حماس افهم ذلك
منك ليس هذا تماما هو هو هو الجوهري في
الموضوع ان تاتي حركه حماس الى انتخابات
وصندوق الاقتراع هو الحاسم من يحكم ومن
يكون رئيس ومن يكون في المجلس التشريعي
طيب والحكومه الجدي هي تتحمل المسؤوليه عن
قطاع غزه الضفه الغربيه اذا رفضت حركه
حماس ذلك فلماذا لماذا تواصل السلطه يعني
الاستجابه الى كل يعني تقديم الخدمات
الاساسيه للشعب الفلسطيني في قطا غزه لا
نريد ان تكون هناك غزه وضف نريد ان يكون
هناك شعب فلسطيني واحد وحكومه واحده ونظام
سياسي واحد ومن يحكم يحكم اذا كانت حركه
حماس فاز فل تحكم هي وتتحمل مسؤوليه
بالكامل هذا هو العض دكتور دكتور مصطفى
الصواف يعني من حيث الظاهر يبدو العرض
واقعي على اعتبار انه يقوم على انتخابات
رئاسيه و تشريعيه ومن يفز هو الذي سيحكم
والا يعني لا يمكن ان تحكم حماس وتقدم
السلطه لها الخدمات بما يعني
انها تغطي هذا الانقسام ما
رايك نعم ربما استمعتم اليوم الى ما تحدث
به الدكتور خليل الحيه القيادي في حركه
حماس عندما وافق وقال ان حماس على استعداد
اليوم ان تجري انتخابات تشريعيه ومجلس
وطني
ورئاسيا لكن محمود عباس لا يريد وفق رؤيته
ان يكون هناك انتخابات للمجلس الوطني لانه
لا يريد ان يوجد شركاء داخل منظمه التحرير
فلسطينيه قد تقف حجر عثره امام ما يخطط له
من مشاريع لتصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه هذا
هو الذي هل يقبل محمود عباس لماذا رفض
المبادره القطريه ورفض ثلاثه بنود اساسيه
منها هي انتخابات المجلس الوطني وكذلك
موضوع الموظفين وهناك ايضا قضيه اخرى هذه
المساله الانتخابات هو يريد محمود عباس
تفصيلها وفق الرؤيه التي يؤمن بها وليس
وفق الرؤ الرؤيه الشموليه التي توافق
عليها الكل الفلسطيني في اعقاب اجتماع
اللجنه التحضيريه للمجلس الوطني في بيروت
هو لم يوافق على الحوار الذي جرى بين حركه
حماس وحركه فتح برعايه نبيه بري وعندما
اتفق الطرفان على قضايا رفضها محمود عباس
عندما عادوا الى رام الله محمود عباس لا
يريد الا وجهه نظره يريد ان ياتي الكل
الفلسطيني اليه اما ان يذهب هو الى الكل
الفلسطيني هذا هو الذي يسبب هذه الامه
اجراء عملي الان نحن امام اجراء عملي هناك
وافد من فتح سيصل الى القطاع للتباحث اي
فيما يحمله من رؤيا تقوم على موضوع
الانتخابات وانهاء الانقسام وما الى ذلك
الى اي مدى يمكن ان تستجيب حماس او تتجاوب
مع هذه
المبادره طب هل تعتقد ان الواقع يحتاج الى
مزيد من التفاوض ومزيد من المباحثات
اولا اي وفد من حركه فتح يرسل لا يحمل
امكانيه اتخاذ القرار ثم هو ربما يريد ان
يوصل رساله وهو يحمل السيف على رقبه حركه
حماس والقوى الفلسطينيه كيف يمكن ان يكون
هناك تفاوض وسيف مسلط على الرقاب هذا
الوفد ام مرحب به كما قالت حركه حماس في
قطاع غزه لانه فلسطيني وغزه مفتوحه لكل
الفلسطينيين ولكن الذي هم يريدون هو حوار
ثنائي والحوار الثنائي جرب اكثر من مره
وكانت النتائج فيه تقلب امام وسائل
الاعلام الان ما هو الذي يضر حركه فتح
ومحمود عباس والسلطه ان يكون الحوار وطني
فلسطيني شامل هذا هو الذي تسعى اليه حركه
حماس في ظل ترحا بها بهذا الوفد الذي انا
في اعتقادي لا يحمل اجنده الا اوامر محدده
من قبل السيد محمود عباس ولا يملك القرار
لتنفيذ بعض القضايا التي يتم التوافق
عليها اشكرك جزيلا الدكتور مصطفى الصواف
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي من غزه واشكر من
رام الله الكاتب الصحفي محمد
هواش مشاهدينا في الملف الثالث من الحصاد
تناقش وسيله علمي ازمات ما توصف بالمناطق
المهمشه في تونس في ضوء اعتصام مستمر في
مدينه تطاوين في الجنوب الشرقي للبلاد
للمطالبه بالتنميه والتشغيل